[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today time dilation
time is an essential concept for
describing our world
the passing of time allows us to
quantify the evolution
and the movement of objects
at first glance one might think that
time is absolute
with a single clock for the whole
universe
at the beginning of the 20th century a
discovery drastically rocked our
previous understanding
relativity time is no longer absolute
it is relative each object has its
own time its own clock
and two initially synchronized clocks
that follow
different paths through space can meet
again and indicate different
times in 1971
an experiment was carried out using
atomic clocks aboard two airplanes
after traveling around the earth in
opposite directions
the two initially synchronized clocks
showed a difference
the contents of the first plane clock
passengers and everything else it
contained
appeared to have aged 300 nanoseconds
less
a small difference nonetheless
detectable by these very precise clocks
how do we explain this phenomenon how
can it be that one of the two clocks had
aged less than the other
has time dilated has it passed more
slowly
to understand this phenomenon
intuitively it will be useful to first
consider a situation that seems
completely unrelated
we simply imagine a meadow on which
person a
walks straight ahead at a steady pace
counting her steps a measures the
distance she travels across the plane
on this meadow there are two trees and a
is oriented such that on the 20th step
she passes both trees at the same time
now a second person b is also moving
straight ahead
but not in the same direction from his
point of view
b does not pass both trees at the same
time he first passes the tree on the
right
then the tree on the left
for a the passing of the two trees is
simultaneous
but for b it occurs at different times
the order of passage depends on the
direction
in which one is moving
let us imagine that a observes the
footsteps left by b
from her point of view a does not
perceive the direction of these tracks
she only observes that they seem closer
together as if b had marked shorter
steps
likewise for b the trace is left by a
seem contracted
[Music]
in reality a and b walk at the same pace
the tracks are identically spaced
it is just a question of perspective due
to different orientations
finally imagine that a and b walk in the
same direction
but that this time the ground is not
flat
b has to walk across a hill
again for a the tracks left by b appear
to be contracted
as if they were shorter and once again
it is just a question of perspective
the steps are equally spaced but they
are oriented differently
along the slope of the hill and thus for
a
they seem shorter
to sum up when two people compare their
footsteps
they can observe shorter steps appearing
to be contracted
either if the directions are different
or if the surface is curved
this contraction is however only an
effect of perspective
in reality the two individuals always
walk at the same pace
[Music]
now let's go back to our initial problem
according to relativity objects in the
universe move across a surface called
space-time
it is a fairly complex four-dimensional
surface but to simplify we can imagine
it as two-dimensional
just like the meadow in our example
in space-time all objects move
and as they progress along their
trajectories the clocks of each
object tick the time they carry passes
as they move forward
the time carried by an object is
therefore equivalent to the footprints
in the meadow
the seconds that pass on our clocks
measure the distance
we travel through space-time
it is very important to understand that
all objects
whether it is a human an apple a star or
an atom
all move at the same rate
within one second they always travel the
same distance
about three hundred thousand kilometers
through space-time
but not all in the same direction
each observer carries two axes
one they call time tangent to their
trajectory
and along which they're clock ticks and
another axis
perpendicular to time which they call
space
an object that moves in the same
direction as us seems to be
stationary the object is still moving
through space-time
but on the axis we call space it does
not change position
conversely if the object moves along a
direction
different from ours it appears to us to
be in motion
its position varies on the axis we call
space
this is called speed
the speed between two objects is the
angle
between their trajectories
as in the meadow if we imagine two
events that occur at the same time for
us
[Music]
these two events can occur out of sync
for someone else
who would be oriented differently
simultaneity
is relative
be careful this is not just an optical
illusion but really a difference
in perspective the two observers have
different definitions
of what they call time and space their
axes are not the same
hence these different perceptions
[Music]
as in the meadow if we observe an object
in motion compared to us
we perceive its time axis from a
different perspective
as if it were ticking at a different
pace
in reality the times of the two objects
tick at the same rate
but in different directions
it is this effect we call time dilation
we understand that this is not really a
dilation
the ticking of time has not changed it
is simply
a matter of perspective
imagine a set of twins that is separated
with one remaining on earth
and the other making a round trip at
high speed through space
since the paths don't have the same
length through space time
at their reunion the twins are no longer
the same age
in the experiment with the airplanes the
explanation is similar
the two planes separate follow different
trajectories through space-time
and it turns out that one of these
trajectories is longer than the other
in terms of distance through space-time
the clocks have not traveled the same
distance
and therefore do not measure the same
durations
[Music]
finally if space-time is curved which is
the case around a massive body like
earth
we will also perceive a kind of time
dilation
the seconds seem to tick at different
rates for objects at different altitudes
twins who separate live at different
altitudes then reunite
will not have traveled the same distance
through space-time
and therefore one of the twins will have
aged more than the other
in the extreme situation which the slope
would be vertical
an object moving there would seem frozen
in time from the outside
a situation analogous to the horizon of
a black hole
[Music]
to conclude the analogy of the meadow
gives us a good geometric intuition
of what we call time in relativity
objects all move along a surface
space-time
and each have their own time and space
axes
such that when they are oriented
differently the durations and distances
they measure
are different
the analogy however has its limits it is
not perfectly equivalent to relativity
in particular in the meadow the
footprints appear to be contracted
while in relativity the time of a moving
object
seems to be dilated
another difference in the plane it is
possible to turn around
you can go back on your steps but in
space-time
even though objects can accelerate as
much as they want
change direction their trajectories are
restricted within a cone
the peculiar geometry of space-time
prevents them from turning backwards
in this weird geometry the pythagorean
theorem
no longer holds this trajectory is
shorter than this one
and there is a kind of speed limit the
speed of light
we call this laurentian geometry
[Music]
you